do you do a lot of drugs did you do a
lot I like shrooms a lot yeah and you do
that occasionally often are you on one
now now I did it three days ago no those
are okay now those are amazing yeah well
we went to a concert
I did a show with Bert Kreischer at Red
Rocks right and then the next night we
saw a band that did shrooms what band
you see Wilco I don't know I didn't know
him either but they were they were Jammy
they were fun I mean you're on shroom so
I could have been watching Al-Qaeda and
it would have been fun all right and is
that the only drug you do yeah I'm not a
big weed guy I'll take a gummy to sleep
because I'm not a I'm a horrible sleeper
but uh I don't like smoking weed
you know all the bad stuff comes out I'm
a I'm a booze bag you like drinking yeah
it's a problem is it a problem I'd say
so why why is it a problem because you
drink so much are you no I'm asking if
it's because you get crazy when you're
drunk or no I drink too much and the
hangovers and then you stay up too late
you do crazy things when you're drunk
and then you sorry about it the next day
yeah
yeah I believe but I've gotten better
with that my 20s was just uh what's the
craziest thing you did when you were
drunk boy I mean you jump off a roof you
drive you I remember one time I jumped
off a roof yeah we jump off into pools
and stuff uh one time I passed out in my
mom's car and I woke up to a cop tap it
on the window sun's coming in I've
covered in urine and uh yours yeah good
and it was leather seats so it really
just pooled right and uh the cop goes
what are you doing and I look around I'm
in the projects of New Orleans and my
mom's Lexus
and uh they go we got a call saying
there was a dead white kid in Alexis in
the projects and I was like oh I'm good
and uh they said all right can you step
out of the car I'm soaking wet show the
guy my ID my wallet's dripping and uh
did he take it in his hand no no no but
he uh he said are the keys in the
ignition and they weren't thank God and
so he goes all right we'll have some
money pick you up
so I got out of it because if the keys
were in the initiative right and then
you see they they took you home yeah did
your mom did your mom say Where's My Car
no they were out of town I stole the car
okay oh you stole a car yeah I mean I
was 18 19. hmm different times and but
did she not um they're out of town did
you did the leather not smell like urine
later I cleaned the hell out of it but
of course they called my neighbor who
picked me up and then my neighbor told
my parents so they did you get in
trouble oh yeah
what was the punishment for that I think
I got grounded you weren't allowed to
take the car anymore no no and they did
they potty train you no I was a
bedwetter so whenever I blacked out I I
would come back I would wet the bed
again I peed on many a one-night stand
Jackie remembers
but uh did you you pee in a in a woman's
bed many times so you're a bedwetter all
the way into adulthood only with the
drinking I probably stopped when I was
14 but then when you blackout happens he
still wet the bed so um when you went to
bed in a date's house what do you what
like what did you say my first attempt
was to blame them I go what the hell did
you do you know and that rarely worked
because it was just a pool of urine
around me and not them so that really
worked so how did she respond well as
some girls some women are so nice you
know like I'll wake up and I'm like ah I
went to bed which is you know not a sexy
way to be around a lady and they're like
ah geez all right get up and you flip
the mattress so you rip the sheet off uh
and then some women are like what the
[ __ ] I'll kill you get the hell out of
my house you know so but when they when
you get up with the ones that get up and
they take the sheet off and you turn the
mattress around and then you remake the
bed yeah do you stay after that no
is too great I have to leave and do you
call them do you ever call him again
I'll send flowers sometimes I'll do
their dry cleaning out of guilt
I know someone that peed in a dresser
drawer oh yeah that's pretty my name is
drunk yeah I've peed in Corners because
you know you're not you're not all there
yeah yeah you never urinated anywhere
you weren't supposed to or how I don't
remember I don't know I don't think I
have I don't think I've I was a bed
wetter also but I don't think yeah but
until about maybe 10 years old and I
don't think I wet anybody else's bed but
my own that was really that's that
builds character oh you're supposed to
do it sleep with friends house I'd stay
up all night like a like a like a Nazi
you know like on a Stakeout and because
I didn't want to fall asleep or else I'd
wet the bed
wow so you're up all night
Like A Nazi well you know how they have
to stay up and then you just you killed
Jews no no one said he likes Jews no I
know but I'm just saying to avoid
urinating sometimes you have to distract
yourself
as a Nazi that's right that's what I was
saying yes you have fun on this podcast
yes it's great
[Music]